[Music]
in the previous video we defined what it
means for a symmetric matrix to be
positive semi-definite in this video as
promised we will use this definition to
solve the problem of finding the
smallest possible inner product between
three unit vectors
crucially what we will discover along
the way is a general technique for
searching for positive semi-definite
matrices that is called semi-definite
programming
this is a technique that anyone
interested in optimization should see at
least once in their lifetime and if we
stay until the end of this video i will
even show you how easy it is to solve
some indefinite programs with python
so in our quest to solve this geometry
problem we will need one additional fact
about positive semi-definite matrices
we have already seen that multiplying by
a positive semi-definite matrix just
like multiplying by a negative number
keeps the output in the same side as the
inputs
well it turns out that positive
semi-definite matrices are similar to
the negative numbers in yet another way
now negative numbers have the following
interesting property they are the only
numbers that have a square root this
factor remains true for matrices as well
positive semi-definite matrices are the
ones that have a square root in other
words a matrix a is positive
semi-definite if and only if you can
write it as c transpose times c for some
other matrix c why the transpose you
might ask well for one without the
transpose c transpose c is not even a
symmetric matrix there is another reason
that will become clear in a second now
let's see why this makes sense
for this implication take a matrix that
is equal to a square multiply it by x
from the left and the right and with the
slate rearrangement we get a vector
times its transpose or in other words
the norm of the vector c times x which
is negative so any square is a positive
semi-definite matrix
and note that this rearrangement would
not have been possible if there was no
transpose here
for the other implication i have a good
and a bad news the bad news is that this
implication is a bit more complicated to
prove so we will not see a proof here
the good news is that the proof is
entirely constructive and there are
algorithms that take as input a positive
semi-definite matrix and compute its
square root
in python for example you can call the
function square root m for the package
psi pi where the m here stands for
matrix to get the square root
decomposition of a positive
semi-definite matrix
now we finally have all the necessary
ingredients to solve our geometry
problem we do so in two steps the first
step is simply to reformulate the
problem in terms of positive
semi-definite matrices and the second
step is to actually solve this
reformulation
this problem is all about inner products
so let's write them down in a matrix
form
and note that diagonals of this matrix
are all equal to 1 because the vectors x
y and z are unit vectors
now here is a question for you can you
see why this matrix is positive
semi-definite
if you say that this is because it has a
square root you are 100 correct
if you put the vectors x y and z next to
each other to form a matrix and you take
the square you get back the matrix of
inner products
this also goes in the other direction if
you take any three by three positive
semi-definite matrix with ones on the
diagonal you can decompose it as some
matrix times its transpose
and read of the unit vectors x y and z
from this matrix
what this means geometrically is that if
you take any configuration of three unit
vectors x y and z and you consider their
inner products you get a point u v w
whose coordinates make this matrix
positive semi-definite
and conversely for every point that
makes this matrix positive semi-definite
there exists three unit vectors whose
inner products are given by the
coordinates of this point
so from now on instead of talking about
vectors x y and z we can simply talk
about triplets u v and w that make this
matrix positive semi-definite and we
know exactly what the set of those
points looked like we even gave it a
name the elliptop
now it's time for this second step
recall the original question where we
had three unit vectors with the same dot
product that we called alpha meaning we
are on this line u equal alpha v equal
alpha w equal alpha and we want to
minimize alpha meaning that we want to
go down this line as much as possible
while staying inside the ellipto
and just like magic you can read from
this plot that the minimizer is the
point minus one-half minus one-half
minus one-half
so the minimum alpha is minus one-half
and if you want to find the
configuration of vectors x y z where the
inner product between any pair of
vectors is equal to minus one half you
can call the matrix square root function
which leads to the following
configuration
and here i can already hear some of you
scream that this is not completely
rigorous and you are right
first of all you can hardly consider a
plot like this one to be a mathematical
proof also you cannot really plot things
in dimension larger than 3.
one thing you can do though in order to
rigorously find the smallest alpha that
makes this matrix positive semi-definite
is to compute the eigenvalues of this
matrix which are one minus alpha and one
plus two alpha so to keep positivity we
need alpha to be between minus one-half
and one and therefore the optimal alpha
is minus one half this method works fine
here but in general it's not really
practical to compute eigenvalues of
matrices of bigger sizes especially if
some of the entries are unknown what we
need is a more general solution
technique that allows us to take a
symmetric matrix with some unknown
entries and allows us to minimize one of
those entries while keeping the matrix
positive semi-definite a lot of
brilliant minds in mathematics have
thought about this exact problem and
developed a solution for it that is
known now as semi-definite program
semi-definite programming is often
described as the most exciting
development in mathematical programming
in the 90s
nowadays there is a huge number of
efficient solvers and off-the-shelf
libraries that you can use for this
problem
here is how you do it in python for
example using the popular package cvx pi
first declare an unknown variable alpha
and construct the matrix that you want
to make positive semi-definite and let's
call it a
then tell cbx 5 that we want to minimize
alpha while keeping the matrix a
positive semi-definite
and finally and most importantly call to
solve method to get the optimal solution
and here is the kicker in
semi-definition programming you are not
restricted to single entries as your
objective function you can minimize any
linear function of these entries you
want you can also have multiple
constraints that are either scalar
equalities scalar inequalities or matrix
inequalities these capabilities will be
extremely useful in the applications
that we are going to see in the next
video but we can get some appreciation
for them right now by looking at a
variant of our toy geometry problem for
example let's say we want to find three
unit vectors x y and z whose sum of
inner products is larger than two such
that the inner product between say x and
y is minimal
good luck solving this problem by hand
but if you know about summa definite
programming you can easily adapt the
code we saw before to specify the right
objective function and the right
constraints and call the solve method
one thing that we have not talked about
so far is how solvers work internally
that's a topic for another day one
pointer i can give you right now is that
some indefinite programming is a special
case of convex programming and if you're
interested in the topic check out my
video series on convex optimization
that's it for today i hope you get some
appreciation for what summit definite
programming is capable of in the next
and probably final video of this series
we will see two of the best applications
of semi-definite programming one
application to dynamical systems and
another one to combinatorics
as usual if you liked the video make
sure to like and subscribe and see you
next time